welcome back
in this in this the last segment of this
section we're going to we're going to
see an example of hierarchical
clustering applied to a study of breast
cancer
so this is the last part of the segment
this is an example which actually Trevor
and I are both involved in
um
actually 10 years ago now with a postdoc
at Stanford in oncology Therese sorely
um Therese had measured
gene expression
from Gene chips for about 88 women who
had breast cancer were being treated for
breast cancer and Gene special measures
for about 8 000 genes so what that means
is for for each of the 88 patients
there's a quantitative measurement for
each of eight thousand genes
um which measures how how much that Gene
was expressing how active it was for
that woman right and this is a very
common kind of study now where people
look at gene expression to try to
understand the basis of diseases like
breast cancer and figure out whether
there are subtypes of of the disease
which should be treated in a different
way
so this is quite large the amount of
data where 88 patients 8 000
features
she used or we the group used um average
Nike's with correlation metric again
because this is the case where
genes are in the same units in a sense
but they're measured in the same units
but
um
the actual level of gene expression
wasn't very reliable because it varies
across the way it's measured but was
more thought to be more important was
the shape of the the relative expression
of different genes for the same patient
so that's why we use correlation metric
um and we did harmful clustering of the
samples of the 88 patients
now when Therese first used the full set
of genes the clustering she got out
wasn't uh wasn't satisfactory now what
does that mean well it's again it's very
subjective but
uh it didn't it wasn't very informative
to her to to Therese and her
collaborators so rather they use a
subset of the genes called the intrinsic
Gene so this is a a way of choosing a
most more informative subset of genes
and I'll go into the detail except to
say in words in this particular study
these women were given chemotherapy and
there was actually a sample taken before
and after for each woman
and gene expression measurements were
available before and after so what
Therese did was she she defined what
called intrinsic genes so for each woman
for each gene
if each woman we look to see
which genes had the smallest variation
within a woman
within a woman as opposed to between the
88 women
and the ones with the smallest variation
were were defined to be the intrinsic
genes of 500 most this is the 500 genes
with the lowest variation the idea being
again this is a biological concept was
that
genes which didn't vary much in a woman
before and after chemotherapy compared
to the the between one variation were
thought to be intrinsic to her cell
biology
so they are thought to be the ones that
could could best Drive the clustering
and and separate the women in terms of
their biology and maybe their response
treatment they varied a lot between
women but little within women across the
two repeated measures
so doing that we uh we got the following
clustering so what do we see here first
of all this is the um
here are the
500 or so intrinsic genes and this is
called a heat map
and this is a common display for this
kind of data so what do we see here each
row of the heat map is a gene
500 sub genes each column is a woman one
of the 88 women and each pixel is
displayed as either
uh green which is negative so the gene
expression it's normalized so it runs
from something like -5 to plus five so
green would be negative and red is
positive so green means the gene
expression for that Gene for that woman
is lower than average and red means it's
higher than average
and what's been done here is we applied
hierarchical clustering to the columns
that's the women in the way I just
described
in addition hierarchical question was
done to the rows the genes this is done
in both directions and that's why this
picture looks it's got It's uh has
patches of red and green right because
it looks because we've sorted them
basically we've sorted the
hierarchical clustering and we sorted
the observations by the order of the
leaves in the tree both for genes and
both for and for samples
and that's why if we just display the
data in the order we've obtained it this
picture would not look so nice so it
would be
a checkerboard pattern it would look
look very random but see here here it
looks much more structured because of
the clustering has been applied and The
Ordering of the leaves is it's been used
to reorder the
rows and columns
um just to
this actually this kind of display would
actually start used first at Stanford in
the in the genomics labs and around the
time the the gene chip is invented which
is also done partly here at Stanford and
I think this has become very attractive
just because it's just it's a nice way
just to see all the data right if you
have if you're given uh a data set of 88
observations women and in 8 000 genes
that's a lot of data just to even look
at
and so the first kind of challenge is
how do I just make a display so I can
look at all the data and see that the
gross patterns and here this is actually
a very effective display this is one of
the pioneering if it's in the in the
labs of Patrick Brown and David botstein
with gene expression really started so
you know it's kind of sort of fun to
think that a you know a a pioneering
um
piece of science is actually displayed
but that's often the case right some
things some very simple things which
might be seem trivial actually can have
a lot of impact just in this case just
the ability to look at
to arrange and display the data
informatively was very useful and it's
still used a lot today so here's the
full heat map and and then the the
clustering tree is at the top
this is here and it's been expanded out
here and
um it's it's been divided into one two
three
four five six seven eight clusters
um the gray is just basically a unknown
group but the other clusters have been
labeled by names
like normal bazel erb2 luminal a luminal
b these names were chosen by Therese and
collaborators based on the genes that
we're expressing in the group in the
groups so now if we look at this picture
what we've taken is the same clusters
and we've just taken subsets of the rows
that's these five groups and
these are genes which are expressing
highly in one or more of these key
groups like for example here let's see
um
this block of sea genes is expressing
highly in the
red group and the blue group this block
of D genes expressing highly in these
clusters Etc so then uh the oncologist
will will look at this and they'll try
to understand well how are the so these
groups are different with respect to
these particular genes what do these
genes do in the cells and
um
what does it tell us about the these
these subgroups
in particular let's onto the
the last display of this if you look at
these subgroups you look at their
survival of these women these are called
copper survival curves
right
um these are these women were treated
with cancer for cancer and followed up
to see how and hopefully you know uh
recovered some didn't and the survival
curves of the groups are given here so
for example
uh the basal group I believe the red and
the purple which groups are those Basils
uh basil and herbie2
are doing
not nearly as well they're probably
survival is much worse whereas the
um
this group did not group The luminal a
is doing much better
so because the survival is quite
different the scientists were really
wanting to find out how are these groups
different and with respect to what genes
and that gives us a clue as to how the
diseases might be different in the
different groups so that's example of
clustering for in a real scientific
problem that's of importance
so just to wrap up this section now
unsupervised learning is what has been
the topic we've talked about principal
components and clustering uh and that's
they're important in general for for
understanding the variation and grouping
structure of a set of unlabeled data so
they can be useful for themselves
um just by themselves that we saw for
example in the that last example or as a
preprocessor to choose a linear
combination of features for supervised
learning
um and we also saw that the problem is
intrinsically harder than supervised
learning because there's no there's no
label there's no gold standard so we
can't use you can't use prediction error
to figure out how well we're doing we've
just shown you two techniques in in
these presentations principal components
and clustering and those are part of a
big tool by a bag of lots of other
techniques some of them are listed here
like self-organizing Maps independent
component analysis spectral clustering
and many more many more of these are
covered in our book elements of
statistical learning in chapter 14 and
even beyond that there are many others
as well